thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another careful boys
where we are very careful boys I'm gonna
put my sunglasses on for a second
because saying this hurts me a little
bit but we'll be fine what Memories do
you have from 2022
that you would destroy if you could
destroy wow for remembering so if you
could like Men In Black you could just
[__] I had a really [__] sick ass
year last year you did yeah for sure you
sure about that do you remember all of
it yeah
all 1.5 million of it yeah let's go
you wouldn't destroy that memory oh [__]
no because it it really sparked me to
today oh you know sometimes I need a
little bit of pain to like push me or
else I'm just like I just Coast with
life yeah and you're talking about
pegging right
it's a little pain but I don't see
things as like regrets and like you know
like that kind of [__] like I I just the
I just see cause and effect and it's
like oh I just I just wasn't ready and I
didn't learn from you know I just and I
talk about this with hat too it's like
that Luna loss and that that 1.5 million
she she's like I think now you're gonna
make ten because you lost that you're so
pissed off and I'm like why is that and
she goes because imagine if you kept
that you probably would have just like
coasted and I'm like I think you're all
that sounds kind of cool too though yeah
no but you know the I wouldn't be happy
you know what I mean like you wouldn't
be happy like at 10. yeah well the
coasting is because of laziness imagine
he's on a paddle board and he's just
coasting just palm trees he's like nah a
really huge pink paddle board yeah five
paddle boards but I was already doing
that I was already going to Hawaii and I
was already doing snowboarding I was
already doing all that [__] right but
and then here's the thing is that once
joombie would have opened is what I
would have done I would have just paid
for management I would have done all
these different things let somebody else
run it and I would have never got to
learn it the way that I did now and I
unlocked so many other things by being
in that position and and developing
because I would have stayed the same
yeah I would have treated that like the
way I treated JK do you feel like do you
feel like after the Luna stuff you you
leveled up to a thousand percent and I'm
I think I need to have
I will but I I think that that was the
practice I practiced there and then me
and Bart will practice elsewhere and
continuously practice elsewhere we'll
come back here eventually in two years
yes we will I'm campaigning for 2024
y'all who looks good we survived that
long that'll be so sick we will we we're
like the roaches of YouTube I know they
just can't [__] kill us but they do
keep on making better roach killer which
is which by the way good for that
you gotta kill him you gotta kill them
now we can't even cuss in the first 30
seconds telling you they're getting so
good [__] [__] but it's in we're
good you know you know what's really
really ironic that you say this prompt
um another a terribly vulnerable moment
for me I have said twice this year on
one occasion this year last year oh 2022
that there's one particular thing that I
would pay up to a thousand dollars to
erase from Nina's memory Nina what was
it and it was at my cousin's wedding
this year I [__] got wasted I was
best man it was his second wedding we
already did the friends one in like
[__] Mexico we came back with the
family one in uh I don't want to get
[__] up for yeah the family one is the
hardest one dude it's like uncles and
aunties for summaries they just get
under your skin too many people you know
yeah yeah and for some reason I just got
triggered and I I blacked out so I don't
really know but the things that did
flash back were the things that were
told to me that I did and the way that I
was acting oh it was
um let's just say it went so far and
again this is this is really
embarrassing to admit but you know I I
[__] turned I've had to tell people
things and I hate doing that like I said
that it's I mean I've been dating this
only because like it's um
there's growth to be had that's how bad
it was of course
um I was like chucking things I was like
yo I think I was kicking [__] there was
a moment where uh we were pulling we
were um [__] pulled over to a hotel
where like people were getting dropped
off for the after party that I didn't
even make it to even though I was the
best man that's how [__] up I was but
uh I ran away from the car my own car
from the hotel and the next thing you
know like when Nina called me I was in
downtown and I was just apparently I was
just talking to homeless people
and stuff like that I don't go this far
right I rarely get that bless you I
rarely get that far but you sound like a
fun time dude yeah he's fine I didn't I
didn't hurt anybody but by the time we
got home people were worried about you
by the time I got home and again Nina's
the only one who has to watch and deal
with it and I think when one person has
to deal with that that's tough were you
guys married yet no no no I was I was
Chucky you deserve these Thug Life
glasses you don't have Chucky [__] at
home at home and it's just YouTube in
the house just yeah scared like oh no
because she knows that it wasn't at all
endangered towards her but I was just I
was just lashing I threw my home pod you
know what I mean like like actually
what's that you [__] rich guy [__]
speaker rich guy [__] a homepod hey
were you drunk during your uh best man
speech I was I was drunk now
the best man the better man I was drunk
but I was I was Cohan my my real best
man speech was in Mexico not for the
family oh okay wait wait you said you
were throwing stuff at your house yeah
and you said you were lashing out I was
just chucking shouts yelling were you
just taking it out on the couches that I
wasn't taking out of the cats but I will
say one thing that Nina said to me the
next morning when I was like sober well
that like this is the reason why I was
like I wish I could delete this memory
right yeah and the footage huh yeah no
not the footage she said she said I just
hope that like our future children never
have to see that side of you that's it
oh no oh it's the worst Nina you know
what's also you know what's [__]
sweet about that what's sweet about that
is she's also saying if it happens again
she'll stay with you
she didn't say if that happens again I'm
out she she might be meaning as a single
day yeah well hey your brain is [__]
up
I just said how sweet it was am I wrong
I just said how sweet me it was hey
that's like a contract and she said it's
Gucci yeah you could do at least two
more time you do it on a [__] you boy
you know what I heard you're home free
brother you went through the ticker tape
chest first
I I heard you want to have children with
me yeah that's [__] awesome wait
we're gonna [__] later yeah lit see
there's so many things landed in there
that's like you're still gonna let me
cream pie after all this [__] that I
put you through hey hey hey see I'm a
positive man this is why it's difficult
to share stories here why we got your
hat Nina's awesome Nina's the best moral
story Nina's chill as [__] dude Nina
wants to take cream pies is that what
that's what you're saying so there's
nothing do you feel like there's
anything
no because in my head what I heard was
Nina
fart fart
wait what's that from nothing nothing
all right dude Anthony put me in timeout
I'm gonna be quiet that is enough okay
boys Anthony put me in timeout we gotta
wrap it up you guys are just making
Ryan's difficult job harder yeah
you can't use it it's like censor it's
like patreon so he can't clip it he
can't talk it yeah there it is but
that's honestly that's what I heard I'm
like that's really cool of her that
she's like that's why we never fight
thinking about your household and she's
she's gonna she's ride or die which is
awesome is there any any positive
byproducts that came from this happening
I literally uh I chilled out on my drink
for the whole rest of the year I I never
allowed myself to get to a point where I
was like super drunk again and he made
some friends from with the guys from
downtown would you did a certain mixture
of drinks or was it just excess like um
you know when like uh you hear some guys
your shoes
not just like with alcohol but even like
uh like working out or something right
there's days where you just feel like
you can kill it yeah and then there's
other days when there's nothing wrong
with you but you just feel tired you
can't do it same thing happens with like
drinking there's days where you can
[__] drink and you can like just
destroy everybody and be sober right and
then there's days where you take like
two shots and you're like well I'm yeah
I'm a tie you're on an empty stomach oh
as best man you're running around every
variable that contributed to whatever it
made so I I just went past the line but
you finish your responsibilities at the
wedding at least I finished everything
but I I finished it a little dirty
I came back with no shoes dude I don't
blame you dude I probably take a shot of
wine cooler and start [__] the wall
let's go Joe let's go it was like it's
point three percent it's like I'm
I think learning that there's like
really at the end of the day like no
excuse I think when you're younger you
just feel Invincible you can like do
stupid stuff and it's like you're
forgiven you know what I mean what or
you're just single so you're just like
oh that was crazy and you kind of move
on yeah it's just on you you're like
[__] it but really like anytime you do
that you might be genuinely like uh
making something else super
uncomfortable or putting somebody in a
difficult situation yeah you know what I
mean or just confident without you even
knowing yeah you know it's like oh it's
like I can't believe I survived the next
day you're like oh that was crazy but
really somebody had to take like it
ruined somebody else's night they take
care of you like the whole night and
you're just like oh I made it you know
and it's very selfish so I just feel
like after that I was like I just need
to not get to that point let's do
mushrooms instead if you could have
taken back a moment from 2023 or 22 that
would have been yeah because I couldn't
take bad things out of my control like
Luna or whatever you know I can't talk
about like making the perfect bet or
whatever but like that was a choice and
that was all me you know what I'm saying
that that was all me that like really
ruined other [__] for other people so
now we know you're alcoholic that can't
control your liquor now we know no it
was a one-time thing like I said if you
dialed it back
you like give the whole article Joe's
like wait so what happened
[Laughter]
to yours
what's the prompt again
what does it say Anthony did
no it's not keep Anthony wearing shoes
you give it to the homeless guy yeah
dude this is a cool group chats now
okay now you guys
man I'm really trying to think of one
that uh you don't live a regret I want
to hear your painful nah man you know
what I'll just say this like tell me how
much your life sucks 2022 I felt like I
was just really lucky bro like these
past couple of years oh I hate you it's
true though like I just feel like uh
you're great man I did see I just feel
like I'm very grateful like I just uh
there's nothing that I could think of
that I'd be like I'd take this back and
because you know like answer the
question I'm really bro I really don't
have a thing where I'd be like I wish
this was a race for my memory uh
sometimes you just have a killer you
didn't see like a family member naked or
something and you're like I wish I could
erase that that was a 2021 bro okay yeah
sometimes you just have a camera though
I'm in the same boat honestly and it's
not like I had a killer year like didn't
you already erase the memory when you
took your fanny pack to turn on all the
gas
yeah I did I remember that [__] you guys
ever think about erasing your happy
memories because you know how people
always want to erase your sad memories
but sometimes I'm like let me erase the
happy [__] so I could do it again like
the first time oh I know what you're
talking about like watching like
watching [__] uh Game of Thrones or
something like that and you're like yeah
that's like a Stark in the beginning
yeah Steve's like that's not the problem
it feels good like I never want to erase
my happy memories
like that's not the problem
Alex is life changing the title where
were you such a stickler for the prompts
because Alex is a he runs a tiger should
be a better host yeah dude no uh for me
I wouldn't change a [__] thing
honestly I wouldn't I know that that
seems enough to people why would you ask
this question and then you're like I
wouldn't change the [__] thing after
I [__] confess My Darkest moment of
the year because every [__] time this
[__] happens now you like [__] and now
we get to look golden yeah and it's
perfect what the heck literally this
this Show's a [__] piece of [__] and
to close I wouldn't change a thing the
amount of thousand want to just stab you
honestly it's one of those things too
where you go through something and
you're thankful because you did because
you learned from it and I know that says
nothing thanks Pastor
faster Steve thank you thanks for the
sermon today I've never I've never been
closer to a group of people so I thought
then my boys who when we went through
crypto hell together in 2008 my
wheelchair boys you guys know who you
are a very limited Group by the way it
was cut in half we went from like 65
people to like [__] 30 something
because they all fought because some
people never came back I don't know
where they went but my well chat boys
are like these boys are were with me the
whole time I've been in crypto basically
other than like two years of like
Bitcoin stuff but yeah I found these
boys we all found each other we had to
do the backs on top these guys are like
my brothers in the space and going
through what we went through with Luna
was one of those things where we had
already been through this together so
like we're already back to work the next
day like these these guys like all of us
we're just in there like resourcefully
being like well we know what we did
before let's just [__] do it again
and that kind of confidence it really is
like this innate weirdness where you're
like okay well we know what we did
before to beat the market like and it's
not about like oh you're smart on the
market it's about beating the market
because like there's enough stupid
people who think that Shiba Inu is gonna
like go to one dollar so like if you can
just look deeper than that you can win
because you can get larger positions of
something that is way cheaper and you
have a bigger stake in it and so but it
takes work to do that and so a lot of
people don't do that but my boys do and
so we're in there working and then and
then this time around I think coroner is
having each other's backs like all the
crypto Corners having each other's backs
like that like it was beautiful like
people are just like yeah look we'll be
back we did this before it was awesome
the run-up was awesome The Rundown
sucked we'll be back and so it's just
one of those beautiful things where it's
like yeah the adversity happened but man
I'm glad I did because I want my [__]
Revenge I need it so what did Alex say
the prompt was that you didn't answer uh
what bad members would you destroy if
you could yeah you didn't for me it was
you talking
get you talking yeah right yeah all
2022. you know me and Ryan saved your
ass you were the worst host last year
I'm sorry we're friends camera's on like
we got room
wait we got hey the review is right dude
we got right here hot show you were the
Rotten Tomato of the group by the same
critic that reviewed your high school
shows wow he was generous then the
reviews all right is no one really gonna
answer this [__] prompt well I don't
know man yeah it was great thank you
other than that is anybody else gonna I
guess for for me last year's pretty
crazy
um like I found out my kid had seizures
and then my dad passed in the craziest
way possible
um but I think like Steve like Joe I
think what else brings us together is
like our the way we view things so when
shit's [__] crazy I think it's like
our immediate thing like what's the
lesson how do we get constructed from
this
and one thing that like even what me and
Jill were talking about was um we
already felt like we were really like
tight couple and we had really great
teamwork and that's what we wanted to
establish before we had a kid
and when we had a kid
um in having like these things happen in
one year we bonded even more than we
thought we ever could which is crazy
because like the minute your kid has
like any type of like ailment you know
like the amount of like doctors we go
through we find in health insurance all
that stuff like the amount of teamwork
that happens is pretty crazy and it's
really intensive and then the amount of
like coordination and like how I still
come here every two weeks so we have to
figure out how we get all that stuff
done while still seeing family
um but like none of us ever had an
attitude of like oh [__] this is too
much [__] you know it was like oh we
[__] got this [__] easy though
tiger will be with you and then tiger
will be with me I'll go over here we'll
go over here and it just felt like right
okay with us together anything's
possible like anything can be
accomplished and so even when the
weekend when like my dad passed Geo's
like no for sure you're going uh you're
going to La early you're gonna be with
your mom I'm okay cool I got that
someone who's like what about technical
school in the situation she got all that
house like don't even worry about
everything over here we got the [__]
covered so it was just really really
cool to like do some pretty crazy things
and almost like once in a lifetime
things that both happen in the same year
we were able to combine together so I
guess like
if we didn't have the positive attitude
I would we would want to erase those
things but those things also made like
kind of prove to us how strong we are
together and also
um what we're able to do with each other
and what a sad little man Anthony is
because he because he needs to forget
something that's what I got about [__] I
could talk about the great things I did
like you did right now but I would just
overshadow you with all my stuff
it the biggest regrets I think the
biggest regrets that I have to erase in
2022 will be
um eating at a circus circus what
I'd erase that I would erase that that's
probably kind of good that guy didn't
even know if it was beef
that's his sense of humor I was like
what is this is this beef equals
something like that that was the most
lackluster meals
it was a lackluster meal I like the food
fun time I the food the fun the it was
great the least taught me how to play
crap yes it didn't like it when I heard
you ungrateful [__] complaining about
it I said let me take that [__] away
because you don't deserve it let me
delete this
delete it hey look hey delete it hey let
me be Anthony in 2022. I launched a shoe
who gives a [__]
no Steve we made a shoe I thought you
lost it
I don't want to be part of the show
anymore okay we can't take it
there's lots to shoot how do we top how
do we how do we end the video now we
still have two minutes left a minute
left Anthony top it top it top it and oh
I can overshadow expected better comedy
than that I don't know but I guess
that's why this Channel's dying you
can't do physical comedy hey don't blame
JK that's a Steve attack you know what I
would [__] erase from my brain yeah
watching [__] two girls one cup oh
that's what brought you into the next
year I've never felt Bart hugging me so
hard now we're all on the same page
before yeah that's true yeah see every
memory there's something that good that
comes from it you know by the way I
watch other things around the YouTubes
yeah other people all of a sudden
started watching 201 Club really after
we did it interesting we're influencers
interesting we're starting a new trend
it feels like saying there's people who
don't admit they want JK which I can't
blame them for but they all name the
channels who was it dude God I can't
remember what's up my head you know what
I feel viral you know how we we made a
joke about Captain Planet and if they
were like this and whatever I've seen
some other people make the same joke huh
I'm telling you what did we say people's
just watching people says coppin peoples
ain't crediting all I remember a cabin
plan was Anthony saying he dressed up as
him and got all these like props sick I
did get props I hope Ken deletes this
video though the whole thing
hey you know Anthony the boys won't say
it but I'll say it thank you for sharing
thank you for sharing thank you thank
you for sharing yeah that was seriously
cool hey remember when you talked about
[__] Chucky that was my favorite
moment
not on the white suit oh no
oh
foreign